[Music]
every three years we revalue your
property and update your rating
valuation or RV the RV is what we
estimate your property will sell for on
the 1st of August this year the RV isn't
a market value and shouldn't be used for
insurance or property sales that's
purely for the purpose of rates it's
important to know that an increase in
your property value doesn't necessarily
mean you'll pay more and rates to
explain that we need to look at how
rates are set rates are just one source
of council income and their level
depends on funding decisions made by the
council property value only makes up a
portion of your rates
it doesn't affect fixed charges rates
based on land area or targeted rates
such as the curbside collection service
you chose revaluation doesn't increase
the total amount that council collects
from rates instead that helps us work
out everyone's share if your property
has a lower than average valuation
increase it's likely to have no effect
on your rates and in some cases may mean
you pay less while a higher than average
valuation increase could result in
higher rates we won't know how your new
property value will impact your rates
until the start of the next rates year
you can object to your rating valuation
and details on how to do this will be on
the notices sync to property owners